In Lesson One we learned that a genome
provides genetic instructions for traits and both of these
can be influenced by the environment. Genome is actually
made of DNA, which we'll learn more about in
Lesson Two. The genome is inherited as individual units.
We mentioned they're called genes, which we'll learn about
in a future lesson. And traits are also inherited.
And both traits and genomes are inherited from parents.
And from parents, they're passed on to
children. Traits can be categorized as either
hidden or visible. Physical or behavioral. And
innate or learned. There can be many variants
of any given trait. And generally, they're
separated into 2 categories, as either being
preferred or good traits. Or undesired or
bad traits. Now obviously these words are relative
to each other and they can have different meanings depending on who you ask.
Usually we reserve the term undesired or bad only for traits that cause or
variance of traits that cause sickness or
death. Also remember that traits are inherited
and they can skip generations. They can
appear undilluted but they can also blend.